- Good morning Believe Nation.
Today's message is be present.
Over to you, Chris Evans.
(rooster crows)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- [Interviewer] You said
that there's a search
to be in the moment.
Does that only apply to acting?
- It's everything that
reality looks and feels
and smells and sounds like,
but you know it's not.
And you're completely in
control of that unfolding.
And that's the time where I
really feel the most present.
And I think that's part
of my addiction to acting,
because I struggle to find that in life.
It's a bit harder when there's no script,
and this is just happening
in a chaotic form,
but the hunt for the moment, you know,
the hunt to be present, that's the goal.
Acting is like a temporary
artificial substance.
It's like a drug.
It's great.
My goal in life is to find
that, to be present like that,
in life, it's hard.
- I think it's super
easy to get distracted
as an entrepreneur.
I think entrepreneurs get
distracted all the time.
It prevents you from
accomplishing the big goals
you want to accomplish.
I think there's a couple reasons for it.
I think a lot of entrepreneurs
have ADD diagnosed
or not diagnosed, we just
tend to like to jump around
and do a whole bunch of different things.
I think also part of the reasons is
we don't have a manager,
we don't have a boss.
When you have a boss that's
telling you what to do,
who sets guidelines and objectives,
then you're going to do it,
otherwise you're going to get
in trouble with your manager.
You might get fired.
Who's going to fire you?
You don't fire yourself.
And so you end up letting yourself down.
You say you're going to do this,
and then as soon as it gets hard,
or you lose interest in it,
you jump to something else.
As a result, what a lot
of entrepreneurs do,
is they have all these projects that are
10, 20, 30, 40, 50% done.
Look at all the things that
you started and stopped
and that are kind of sitting
there on the sidelines
and you've done nothing with.
It's super common.
A lot of entrepreneurs do this.
But you don't get the results.
You don't get the fruits.
Unless you take it to 100%.
You're not going to cash in on something
that's 50% done, 20% done,
and as soon as something
gets hard, or as soon
as we hit a roadblock,
a lot of times what entrepreneurs do is
they say, I'm not
interested in that anymore.
That's not what I want to do.
I'm not passionate about that.
I'm going to go and do something else.
Just see if that's your habit.
See how often you actually follow through,
all the way to completion,
that idea you had
or that you started, and
when it got hard, you stopped
and moved on to something else.
And so the two things that
if ind really helped me
is one, having a mission, having a vision.
What do I want to do?
What am I here to do?
I want to help a billion entrepreneurs.
I want to have a big
impact on this planet,
and my path is by
believing in entrepreneurs.
That's what I want to do.
I wake up thinking about the impact
that I want to have today on the planet.
What that does is help get
me through a lot of the crap.
Because being an entrepreneur
is not all roses.
There's a lot of really bad days
that a lot of people don't talk about.
When I was writing my book,
there were a lot of bad days,
and what gets me through is
I want to write this book,
I wanted to inspire lots of entrepreneurs,
I wanted to have an impact.
And so having a clear mission,
understanding the bigger
picture, remembering your why
and what you're doing here,
can help get you through
that final 50% or maybe
even just the final 10%
that's just really hard and you
need that extra little kick.
The second thing that really helps me too
is having a schedule,
so I know what I'm doing
every single day of the week.
I've booked it in.
One day I'm working on my YouTube channel.
One day I'm working on
trying to dance salsa.
One day I'm doing meetings.
And so I have it set up in my calendar
that this is what I'm working on today.
I've allocated the amount
of time that I need
to go off and have a
big impact in that area
of my business or my life.
So those two things.
Remembering the why and scheduling it in
helps take those projects
that may be I would dump
at 50% because I don't
have anybody watching me.
There's no manager holding me accountable.
And allows me to follow
through and finish to 100%
so I can get the rewards that I'm after.
So the question today is, I'm curious,
how do you guys stay present?
How do you guys stay focused?
How do you make sure the
projects that you say
you're going to finish you
actually follow through
and finish them?
Leave it down in the comments below.
Super curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Caitlin Gag.
Caitlin, thank you so
much for picking up a copy
of my book, Your One Word.
It really really really means a lot to me,
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is,
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning.
♫ Entspresso keep me going.
(manual typewriter clicks)
- When I'm playing
football, I appreciate it.
I'm nowhere else.
I'm in the present.
That's probably the
best part about my life
is that to be in the
present, you talk about
how do you enjoy your life?
How do you find balance, right?
It's to live in the present.
To live like a kid.
Like why do kids have so much fun?
Because they just care
about what they're doing.
- Yeah.
- And if we thought about what
we were doing all the time,
you do that when you're
on the football field.
It's probably the only
place I can really do that,
when I really truly am my authentic self.
I mean, a lot of people see it.
My close close friends do.
But when I'm on the football
field, it's just raw.
- I don't like to think too far ahead.
I don't like thinking too far ahead.
People set like goals, long
distance goals and shit.
That's too much for me.
I already feel like I'm living it,
and then I just carry
on, carry on day by day,
already living the final goal,
the goal of being the world champion.
I already carry myself
like a world champion.
I already speak like I'm a world champion.
And that's it.
I just carry on, day by day.
So I'll take it as it comes.
Again, like I said, you
asked me about the future.
I'll let you know a little bit closer,
you know what I mean?
All I can see right now is the gold.
That's all I can see.
- Your background is very well documented,
the things you went through,
which have shaped you.
How much of that is really behind you?
How much do those ghosts still haunt you?
The involvement in issues
that got you imprisoned
and tortured and, you know,
the drug use and so on?
- I am myself and my
circumstances, I think,
like a Spanish philosopher used to say.
So who am I?
I am a son of the experiences
that I lived in my life.
That said, of course, I don't look back,
because if I look back, I may
become a (mumbles) of thought.
So I try to live my life here,
but it is the sum of difficult moments,
good moments, experiences
that I had in my life,
that brought me here in front
of this camera talking to you.
You don't live your life
in this capitalistic sense
that you accumulate knowledge
as you accumulate money.
No no no no no.
Life is about the present moment.
You're here, you're here now,
and then you have an idea
or have some thing, but that
may be a root in your past,
but you don't know, so what I
try to do is to live my life
as full, as intensely, as I can.